chunks of the main road linking hasaka
and raqqa in northeastern Syria have
been washed away
and in the fields around it crops of
wheat barley and vegetables have been
destroyed just as they would have been
taking root
heavy rains have raised River levels
that have flooded homes as well as the
tents of syrians internally displaced by
the Civil War
I live alone as my husband is dead the
house flooded while I slept my sons
rescued me all my possessions are wasted
I've lost everything I only have the
clothes on my back we spend the whole
night in the open
this region in Syria has been controlled
by Rebel forces for 12 years there's not
much maintenance of public roads
buildings and Facilities
the area is home to around four and a
half million people according to un
figures seventy percent of them are in
desperate need of humanitarian
assistance
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera